la orejona engalana la plaza de rocío y
lisboa es hoy el centro de atención de
los amantes del fútbol aquí se disputa
la fase final de la liga de campeones
por el coronavirus los partidos se
disputan a puerta cerrada los pocos
hinchas de los encuentros por televisión
en bares y restaurantes un sector que
pudo reactivarse en comparación con los
tres meses en los que no había deportes
y para un bar como el nuestro ha sido
difícil y ha sido un regalo del cielo
sin embargo no todos los lisboetas
comparten ese entusiasmo a pesar de ser
un país de fútbol más saben lo que está
en juego el turismo representa el 18 por
ciento del producto interno bruto
portugués no se siente un cambio esta
competición en portugal es como si no
existiera la parte web lo bueno es que
hay menos gente y se camina mejor en la
ciudad lo malo es la parte económica los
turistas hacen falta es un país que vive
esencialmente del turismo
por causa del virus la mitad de los
hoteles de la ciudad aún no tenían
clientes hace dos meses la liga de
campeones es entonces la vitrina ideal
para lisboa es un instrumento
fundamental para reestablecer la
confianza en este destino
de su virtud y sobre todo para
restablecer una imagen positiva de
lisboa de portugal en general la capital
espera en los próximos meses el regreso
contundente de los turistas extranjeros
a menos de que una segunda ola de kobe
19 dañe los planes